we're looking at how the pandemic is
affecting diverse communities
economically and medically and this
morning we're focusing on disparities in
particular in healthcare as coronavirus
cases spike in much of the country rates
of infection hospitalizations and deaths
are higher for minorities black
Americans make up 13% of the u.s.
population but account for 23% of
coronavirus deaths dr. Jon LaPook takes
us to Minneapolis to show what is behind
these statistics at fellowship
Missionary Baptist Church in Minneapolis
caster Albert Gulman is preaching the
gospel and COBIT 19 prevention whether
you have symptoms are no symptoms you
need to get tested while worshiping
remotely he's stressing the importance
of masks testing and practicing what he
preaches social distancing in the black
community the church has always been a
place where we disseminate information
people may not listen to politicians or
to public health officials but how about
to their pastor yeah relationship I mean
they know their pastor right
Kirstin and Charles Nixon are two of
Pastor Goldman's parishioners in May
their entire family tested positive for
coronavirus your husband.you your three
boys your mother and your father
yes I was having a conversation with my
white neighbors we were in our backyard
talking and I was trying to practice
social distancing and he he wasn't
really understanding it and I said to
him that he needed to understand that
this disease hits black people a lot
harder than his wife one reason is that
when compared to white Americans black
Americans have higher rates of chronic
medical conditions linked to poor
outcomes from kovat nineteen fifty four
percent have hypertension nearly 50
percent are obese and more than 13
percent have diabetes do either of you
have underlying conditions Kirsten
Nixon's 86 year old father is still
hospitalized with complications of kovat
19 the rest of the family had mild to
moderate symptoms but are now doing well
across
Minnesota black people account for over
21% of reported cases but only make up
6% of the state's population that
disparity is echoed across the country
James burrows leads health equity
efforts at Children's Minnesota Hospital
he worked with the State Health
Department to open for corona virus
testing clinics in communities of color
fluid to make sure that those
communities are tested more often and
not only tested realize that you can get
access to healthcare in 2017 more than
10 percent of black Americans were
uninsured compared to roughly 6% of
white Americans Leandre Schley Byrd is
chief health equity officer for the
CDC's coronavirus response
she says the epidemic has highlighted
how certain jobs can increase the risk
of infection there are more people of
color who are over-represented in
essential and frontline work which means
that they don't have the same
opportunity to telework pastor Gorman
says he's eager to get back to
delivering his messages the way he used
to that will help us heal over both the
George Floyd situation and the covet
because then we can come together we can
cry we can laugh we can do that and dr.
Jon LaPook joins us now dr. Luke good
morning those pictures really remind us
what congregating looks like and how
long it's been since we've been able to
do so what's the impact meant on that
community of not being able to get
together in person as a church it's been
huge and good morning Tony you know
pastor Gorman said that he he said he
wants to be able to hug people again
it's a time for fellowship and something
he said really struck home for me he
said especially the elderly people in
his congregation Sunday may be the only
time when they come to church when they
actually leave their homes you know they
get all gussied up they get dressed up
in their church vest and then they're
able to congregate with each other and
talk to each other we know that
isolation is very bad for your health
in fact it increases the risk of
dementia so there's only a certain
amount you can get from a zoom
congregation I know I know John I look
forward to seeing you in person
they soon too as well thank you very
much